quartier notre dame de grâce à montréal
le 28 mai 2010huit deux policiers du
spvm sont en patrouille ici jose les ne
souhaite pas montrer son visage mais il
nous raconte ce qu'il a vécu cette
journée là alors qu'il fait des
emplettes en voiture les policiers le
suivent
parce qu'il semble que la plaque
d'immatriculation ne lui appartient pas
ils interceptent à l'endroit précis où
l'on se trouve chez mobilise le véhicule
je descend de la voiture je les
approches pour savoir si quoi la raison
pourquoi que me suis dit li - tard c'est
pire que ce que j'ai commis aucune
infraction
ils disent que je suis agressif supposer
que je parle fort palaces notent les
mains liées jose les explique que le
véhicule lui appartient et c'est bel et
bien le cas
les policiers réalisent qu'ils ont fait
une erreur
plutôt que de s'excuser il lui remettre
un constat d'infraction pour entrave à
un agent de la paix un constat qu'il
conteste
aussitôt il croit avoir été victime de
profilage racial
on en avait que ça à plusieurs reprises
j'en pouvais plus le juge de la cour
municipale qui a entendu son témoignage
lui donnent raison
dans une décision rendue la semaine
dernière il écrit les policiers
n'avaient aucun motif valable pour
l'intercepter j'arrive à la conclusion
selon la balance des probabilités que
les policiers ont intercepté monsieur en
raison de son profil d'homme noir ce qui
constitue du profilage racial
il se pose la question à savoir si c'est
un homme blanc qui était dans la même
situation à ce que le traitement aurait
été le même cet avocat criminaliste
crois que ce genre de situation se
produit trop souvent même s'il observe
des changements
la preuve de profilage racial est
toujours une preuve qui est indirect va
jamais avoir un dossier dans lequel un
policier de manière claire vaincre dans
son rapport j'ai intercepté monsieur
parce qu'il est noir bien entendu mais
ce qui nous aide maintenant c'est que
les tribunaux supérieurs ont statué sur
le fait que c'est correct ses preuves
circonstancielles là quelque chose doit
changer c'est sûr
invité à réagir le service de police de
la ville de montréal
dit simplement ne pas commenter les
dossiers judiciaires ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada montréal